So, in this video, [music]
no, wait.
So, in this vid, we're going to
break down the
That sounds terrible.
Still recording?
Um I can't get it right. I just don't
sound like
the YouTuber.
Good.
Good? What's good about that? Have you
heard an advice? If you're homeless,
just buy a house.
What the That doesn't make any sense. I
mean, if you don't sound like a
YouTuber, then just use something that
does.
And just like that, I went down the
rabbit hole of
AI voice generators.
>> [music]
>> So,
this is how I actually make an AI voice
sound [music]
real.
Okay, look. Before we get into the
technical stuff, if you want to make a
realistic voice with AI, you need to
understand what the hell makes human
voice realistic in the first place.
Really, like, why does your brain think
you're listening to a real person right
now instead of a computer pretending to
be a ginger dude with a fancy suit?
Well, if you break it down, there are
four elements.
If I keep the same tone throughout the
entire video with no ups and downs in my
voice, that would make it sound robotic.
I talk like that in real life. Oh man,
this robot can talk more human than me?
Anyways, if all of a sudden I change my
tone from monotonous to super excited,
that would make it sound more human.
You probably heard that cutting all the
pauses in your video boosts retention.
Even though that's kind of right, it's
not worth making yourself look like a
lifeless robot that's been controlled by
the algorithms. Instead, pause on some
important points to make your message
more impactful.
And make your AI voice sound more
natural, of course.
Just like making pauses, emphasizing
important words in your script No,
emphasizing important words in your
script is also a powerful way to make
your AI voice sound more realistic.
And lastly, of course, if you use
ChatGPT to write your entire script, no
matter how realistic your AI voice is,
at some point, it will start to sound
robotic. And yeah, if you write your
scripts with AI and think that nobody
knows, trust me, we know.
All right. So, with these four elements,
you can cook a 96.2%
pure AI voice. These are the main things
you need to keep in mind while creating
your [music] voiceovers. And we'll use
each of this in a minute while creating
the actual voiceover. But before that,
we need to
choose a software.
Look, there are so many AI voice
generators out there right now that I
just gave up counting. [music] I tested
almost every single one for this video,
and you know what? Most of them are
fine. They do a decent job at
replicating a human voice. But the one I
always come back to is called
ElevenLabs. So, that's going to be the
software we'll use for this video. And
no, they didn't pay me to say this. I
wish they did, but they didn't. I've
been using it since I started this
channel, and you're seeing or hearing
how realistic it sounds.
Be honest, you sometimes forget it's not
a human voice, right? You don't?
Okay, never mind. There's a link in the
description if you want to check it out
and follow along with your own script.
Just create an account [music] and try
the techniques we're going to use by
yourself. Okay, fine. Let's do this.
So, you know the theory. Now, what do
you need? A voice. This is an important
step because once you pick a voice,
you're basically married to it. All your
future videos, that voice. So, don't
just click the first one you see and
call it a day. You're going to need
something solid. Take your time. [music]
Pick a nice one. Now, there are a few
ways to create a voice.
First, if you want [music] to use your
own voice, you can go with this route.
You may think, why would I clone my own
voice when I can just use my throat?
But, it's going to be a really important
step at the end of the video. Just let
me cook. Click the voices tab, clone a
voice, then instant voice clone, and
upload a sample.
If you got time, you can create a
professional voice clone as well, but
keep in mind that it requires at least
30 minutes of voice sample. Once you
generated your voice clone, you can use
it wherever you want. That's crazy.
Wait, actually,
yeah, that's completely illegal. You
can't clone someone else's voice without
their permission. It's like against
every terms of service ever written. So,
you better use it with your own voice
only. And Finzar, if you're watching
this, please, don't sue me, dude. Get
the hell out of here.
Seems like no AI can say it like the
original.
Now, if you don't like your own voice,
you can choose one of the voices from
the huge voice library here. Oh,
brilliant. Just what I needed. Another
Evil is only frightening. I love the way
you look at me.
Like you already know your mind to me.
>> Anyways, so, the most asked question in
this channel after how you edit your
videos is which voice are you using in
ElevenLabs? Well, the voice you're
hearing right now isn't from the voice
library or a cloned voice.
It's a custom voice.
Most tutorials don't mention this, but
you can actually create an entirely new,
unique voice in ElevenLabs. It's usually
as realistic as the ones from the voice
library while being not available to
everyone with one click. So, it's a
great choice for creating a brand that
doesn't use this voice. No one else can
use it for their channel. Um well, if
they don't clone your voice with the
cloning feature, but you get my point,
right? In the voices tab, click create a
voice and voice design. When I created
my voice a few years ago, this feature
was just a single button that you can
click and hope for a good voice. But
now, you can describe the voice in your
mind however you want. Like, a young man
in his 20s, American accent, speaking
with quirky but charismatic style and
speaks with a lot of emotion throughout
the speech. I don't know. Something like
that. And let's reduce the guidance a
bit to see what it comes up with.
Hey there. So, I was just thinking,
wouldn't it be wild if we could like
teleport?
Imagine the possibilities. No more
traffic, just poof, you're there. Damn!
Can I change my voice to that? No? Okay.
Now, if you found a voice that works for
you, we can move on to
generating the actual voiceover. At this
point, you have a nice voice and you
know what a realistic voice sounds like.
So, you can just copy your script, paste
it to ElevenLabs, and hit gen Wait, hold
on for a second. Of course, you can do
it. You may even get a pretty good
result from it as well. But if you do
that, so and after listening to it for a
few minutes, something will feel
>> [music]
>> off. And the viewer is going to feel it
as well. I don't know what it is, but
it's there in all AI voices. It's like
they follow a pattern that just gives it
away. And once you notice it, you can't
un-notice it. So, let me show you how I
generate my voiceovers. [music] It takes
much more time, but it's the only way I
found to get rid of that uncanny
feeling. And it's probably the secret
sauce that makes you wonder how this
ginger dude sounds so realistic. All
right, enough yapping. Let's get
started.
First off, put the script down slowly.
We have to choose a voice model first.
V3 is their latest model. It can do
crazy stuff like making the voice
giggle,
whisper, or be excited. That sounds
great, right? But when I tried it with
my own voice, it sounded like this.
Who the hell is that? That's like my
evil twin or something. I even tried it
with other voices, and every time, it
slightly changes the voice itself. So,
you can give them a try if you want.
It's still in the alpha stage, so
hopefully, it will be more stable in the
future versions. But it's not really
usable right now. So, I use the V2 model
instead for all my videos. Unlike V3,
this model has a few more sliders.
Increase the speed, reduce the
stability, and
change that annoying music. I'm trying
to focus here, dude.
Thank you. Drag the similarity to
something like 70% and increase the
style exaggeration.
Now, select just a few sentences from
your script and paste it to ElevenLabs.
What did we needed for a realistic
voice? Changing tone and speed, pauses,
emphasis, and writing like a human. I
assume you already nailed the last part.
So, let's focus on the other three.
Using three dots makes the voice sound
disappointed or confused. To make it
more excited, use exclamation marks. It
always works. If it doesn't, use more
exclamations. We'll play with the pauses
in the editing, but you can try three
dots or commas to make them a bit more
natural. And for emphasizing important
words, write them in all caps. Another
example, this is how it sounded like
before making the changes. Say my name.
You're Heisenberg.
You're goddamn right. Pretty normal. And
this [music] is how it sounds after
making the changes. Now,
say my name.
You're Isaac.
You're goddamn right. Sounds much
better. But if you're not happy with how
the result turned out, you can generate
it again a few more [music] times.
You're goddamn right. You're goddamn
right. You're goddamn right. You're
goddamn right. But why are we generating
a few sentences at a time? Couldn't we
do the entire script at once? Well, we
could, but we shouldn't. One reason is,
if it generates a bad take, we can
easily regenerate it without wasting too
much credits. But the second reason,
this is the secret sauce. If you
realized, each time you hit generate,
the tone changes slightly. The tone
changes slightly. The tone changes
slightly. Even though we input the same
text. So, we're taking advantage of
that. For each generation, you get two
extra regenerations for free. Use those
free generations and download them as
well. You're going to see why in the
editing part. With every batch we
generate, we get a slightly different
tone and speed. That's just like how
normal humans sound like. So, when
combined together in the edit, it makes
the final result sound more natural and
fixes that uncanny feeling we talked
about earlier. After knowing these, it
just takes a few hundred more
generations and you get this. Yes, it
takes ages, but it's like cooking. Small
changes make a huge difference. Now, put
them all in a single folder, select
everything and rename. That's much more
organized. Now, we can move on to the
next step.
I'm going to show this in Premiere Pro,
but you can do it in any editing
software that has a timeline. Import the
voice-overs you generated to Premiere
Pro and start choosing the best takes.
Don't worry about timing or anything
else at this point. Just line the
voice-over based on your script. If you
downloaded a few versions of the same
sentence, [music] listen to all and
choose the one that fits the context
better. But, the real magic happens when
you chop some parts from each generation
and combine them together. For this
sentence, I generated three versions.
Let's listen to each one. But, the real
magic happens when you chop some parts
from each generation and combine them
together. But, the real magic happens
when you chop some parts from each
generation and combine them together.
But, the real magic happens when you
chop some parts from each generation and
combine them together. Now, they sound
good on their own, but to make it more
human-like, I took the best sections
from each version and got the final
result. But, the real magic happens when
[music] you chop some parts from each
generation and combine them together.
Once you got a long straight line, start
cutting the pauses. Use [music] the
second line to start the next sentence
right after the last one ends. But,
don't forget to add pauses
and intentional spaces for the important
parts of your video. Now, even though
Eleven Labs had a speed slider in its
editor, you may realize just now that
your voice-over is too slow [music] or
too fast. Don't worry, it happens. I
mean, I'm not the only one, right?
Premiere Pro allows you to change the
speed, but it turns you into a chipmunk
if you do that. Oh, there's an option to
keep the pitch. There we go. How's that
sound? Oh, great. It distorts the voice
now.
Is it really that hard to make a speed
changer, Adobe? Fine, I'll do that
myself.
Great, the voice-over is almost ready.
But, we can make it sound more [music]
professional. Here's something new I
learned for this video. Take the
parametric equalizer effect, add a
high-pass filter, increase the H value,
find echoey frequencies, find the echoey
frequencies, or just drag and drop the
preset I made. I also added a few fun
voice effects and other useful stuff as
well for you to [music] try out. So,
feel free to download the pack from the
description. Well, I think we're done
here. But, wait a minute.
What does YouTube say?
Does it allow using AI voices? Even more
important, does it allow monetizing
videos with AI voices? Yes.
What? You expected a long list of
explanations? Haha.
I mean, as long as you're making an
original content, not a funny videos
compilation, yeah, you should be fine.
But, should you be fine? I mean, should
we all just start using AI voices now?
What about, I don't know,
authenticity?
Wow.
That's better than I could ever do.
>> [music]
>> See? Told you it would work. Sounds
great, man. Yeah, but
it's just
not me. What's wrong, man? You're
becoming a YouTuber. Wasn't that what
you wanted?
I don't know. It feels like cheating. It
feels like I'm becoming a fraud, dude.
A fraud?
>> [music]
>> You want to know what's fraud?
That.
Silence. [music]
Having something worth saying and
keeping it locked up because you're too
scared of how it sounds.
>> [music]
>> That's fraud. Who says it should sound
like you? As long as it's your own
thoughts, who cares how it sounds, huh?
Come on, we don't have time for this.
He was [music] right.
I was so obsessed with how I sound, I
was forgetting the most important part,
[music] actually saying something
valuable.
Yeah, I mean,
I could end this video here and call it
a day, but that's not all.
I kept the best part for the last.
I get it now. [music] It's a great
solution if you don't have a mic or if
English isn't your first language.
I mean, at least that's progress,
[music] but you're thinking too small,
dude. You're still thinking about
replacement. Don't you see? Everything
you learned, this isn't [music] just
about finding a voice. There's a bigger
picture. Man, talk in English, I don't
understand. Okay. Name a big YouTuber. I
don't know. Does Mr. Beast count? Too
cliché, but okay. When did his videos
start to get viral? I mean, he had over
10 million subs in 2018.
>> Yeah, but I mean super viral. Look here,
2023.
Yeah, that's quite a jump.
>> Now,
>> [music]
>> when did he start dubbing his videos?
2023.
>> Exactly. Ruhi Cennet, Mark Rober, Joe
Hattab. Anyone who started dubbing his
videos to other languages suddenly
doubled, tripled their views and
subscribers. Does it really make that
much difference? Think about it. There
are 2.5 billion active YouTube users
[music] in the world. Around half a
billion of them speaks English. That's
less than 20%. If we just add up the
next five most known languages to this,
it makes up almost half of the entire
YouTube.
>> see the potential?
>> [music]
>> Well, that was [music] the twist. AI
voice-over isn't just for narrating your
scripts for you. It's real superpower is
dubbing your videos. You can dub your
videos and get a massive audience. To
try it myself, I added just two
languages to my last video and the
results were pretty clear. Oh, it's
actually blurry.
Don't worry, I'll show it after showing
how to dub your videos. As an example,
let's take my last video. I already
dubbed it into Spanish and Hindi, so
let's do Portuguese now.
Before we touch any AI, we need to
separate the ingredients. After
finishing your video, go to your editing
timeline, mute everything except the
voice-over and export as an MP3. Next,
do the opposite. Mute the voice-over and
export an MP3 with only the music and
sound effects. You'll see why in a
second.
Now, go to Eleven Labs and click the
dubbing tab. Create a new dub. Select
your original language, the target
language and upload that voice-over we
just exported. Hit generate and um go
make yourself a coffee. It takes a few
minutes.
Once it's done, download the file and
drag it back into Premiere Pro. Here is
what you need to build here. The top is
your original native voice. We're going
to use this as a guide for timing.
Middle is the new AI Portuguese voice
and the bottom line is for music and
sound effects we exported earlier. Line
them up so the timing matches the
visuals. Once it sounds good, mute the
original English track. Slap my preset
on the Portuguese track to make it sound
crispy [music] and export just the
audio.
Now, the only thing left is to add it to
your video.
In YouTube Studio, click languages and
choose the video you just dubbed. Make
sure YouTube didn't automatically dub to
that [music] language with their Google
Translate voice. If so, just delete it
from the menu here, then click here,
select the dubbed language and upload
your audio file. Also, translate your
video title and description with ChatGPT
to reach the 99.1%
purity and you basically unlocked a new
country. Keep repeating it for other
languages as well and you tripled your
potential audience size. Now, as
promised, here's what it looked like in
the analytics tab.
So, yeah, it doesn't look that
impressive, does it? I mean, where's the
millions of views?
Well, hold on. If you look at the views
by audio track instead, this is how it
looks like.
Here's YouTube's auto-dubbed Hindi track
and this is where I added the Eleven
Labs version. That's what I'm talking
about. And this is the difference in
Spanish dub.
Wow.
That's
thousands of people who watched my
video.
People who would have seen none of it if
I had listened to that voice in my head.
Turns out Steven was right.
>> [music]